Wolfgang
Amadeus Mozart is known for many things, few
of which we care to cover on this site because
you probably already know all about them.
Instead, we prefer to cover things that you
likely didn’t know, like that the alphabet
song was based on a tune by Mozart, or covering
his extremely adult themed works that included
a bit of an obsession with all things scatological,
and the significantly more family friendly
subject of today- that time Mozart pirated
a cherished choral arrangement from the Vatican,
reportedly all from memory.
That piece was Miserere mei, Deus (literally,
“Have mercy on me, O God”), which was
based on Psalm 51 and composed by Catholic
priest Gregorio Allegri sometime in the 1630s.
Although today Miserere is regarded as one
of the most popular and oft recorded arrangements
of the late Renaissance era, for many years,
due to papal decree, if one wanted to hear
it, one had to go to the Vatican.
The punishment for ignoring the ban on copying
this music is widely stated by many a reputable
source (as well as Mozart’s dad, Leopold)
to be excommunication from the Catholic church.
(Although I couldn’t find any primary documents
that back Pope Urban VIII, or any other Pope,
ever making such an official decree, and various
pirated versions of the music are known to
have existed during the moratorium without
anyone seeming to have been excommunicated.)
Nevertheless, there was indeed a ban on copying
the music that lasted for almost a century
and a half.
To add to the mystique surrounding the piece,
it was only allowed to be performed publicly
on two specific days during the Holy Week
(the week before Easter)- Holy Wednesday and
Good Friday.
(And if you’re curious, see: Why Determining
Easter’s Date is So Confusing) All this,
combined with the superior acoustics of the
Sistine Chapel and the unparalleled talent
of the Papal Choir resulted in the piece becoming
an almost mythical entity, with people travelling
from across the globe to hear it performed
in all its glory.
Though the Vatican refused for many years
to ever release a copy of the sheet music
for the piece, by the mid eighteenth century
the Church had been cajoled into gifting three
copies to prominent individuals.
These individuals were the King of Portugal,
famed composer and Catholic friar Giovanni
Battista Martini, and Emperor Leopold I.
In regards to Emperor Leopold, he seems to
have heard the piece on a visit to the Vatican
sometime in the late 1600s, becoming enamoured
with it.
Leopold used his influence to convince the
Pope to give him a copy of the sheet music.
He then summoned the finest singers he had
at his command and arranged for a performance
of the piece to be held in the Imperial Chapel
in Vienna.
By all accounts, the resulting performance
was lacklustre and dull.
This supposedly resulted in the Emperor believing
he’d been cheated and given an inferior
copy of the music, sending a courier to the
Vatican to explain to the Pope what had happened.
Apparently upset himself over his orders not
being followed, the Pope subsequently is said
to have dismissed the Maestro di Cappella
who’d provided the music.
As it turns out, Leopold had indeed been sent
a genuine copy of the sheet music.
However, over the years the Papal Choir had
added many embellishments to the original
work that were not reflected in the sheet
music, nor were they seemingly ever written
down.
The story goes that the Maestro di Cappella
eventually got his job back when this was
explained to the Pope.
Whether that oft’ told story is perfectly
accurate or not, Emperor Leopold would later
enshrine the copy of Miserere he’d been
given in the Vienna Imperial Library.
This all brings us to 1770 when a 14-year-old
Mozart was touring around Italy with his father.
After arriving in Rome, Mozart attended the
Holy Wednesday Tenebrae, during which he heard
Miserere in full.
Later that day, Mozart, who was already considered
a musical prodigy at this point, transcribed
the entire 15 or so minute piece from memory.
He is also rumoured to have attended the Good
Friday performance later that week to hear
it again, helping to improve upon his unauthorised
copy.
(Popular myth states that he smuggled his
copy into the performance in his hat and corrected
it on the spot.)
Despite knowing that copying the piece was
taboo, Mozart’s father, Leopold, was reportedly
impressed that his son had managed to transcribe
the song from memory, writing in a letter
to his wife dated April 14, 1770:
You have often heard of the famous Miserere
in Rome, which is so greatly prized that the
performers are forbidden on pain of excommunication
to take away a single part of it, copy it
or to give it to anyone.
But we have it already.
Wolfgang has written it down and we would
have sent it to Salzburg in this letter, if
it were not necessary for us to be there to
perform it.
But the manner of performance contributes
more to its effect than the composition itself.
Moreover, as it is one of the secrets of Rome,
we do not wish to let it fall into other hands.
Unlike the other, authorized copies of the
piece that existed at the time, Mozart’s
supposedly included the multitude of flourishes
and ornamental embellishments employed by
the choir that were of fundamental importance
to the arrangement, but, as previously stated,
not in the original music by Allegri.
All this said, while that is the widely reported
story, it should be noted here that it isn’t
actually clear from evidence at hand how accurate
Mozart’s copy of the piece was, as it has
unfortunately been lost to history, and going
off a boasting father’s account is somewhat
suspect.
However, for those who support the idea that
Mozart made a perfect copy, it is noted that
Miserere is an amazingly repetitive piece,
with the gist of most of the arrangement coming
in the first few minutes.
It’s also often stated that a short while
after transcribing Miserere, Mozart was at
a party with his father when the topic of
the tune came up in conversation, at which
point Leopold boasted to the guests that his
son transcribed the legendary piece from memory,
prompting some amount of skepticism from the
attendees.
However, in attendance at said party was a
musician named Christoferi, who’d actually
sung it while a member of the Papal Choir.
After looking over the copy made by Mozart,
he supposedly confirmed that it was a faithful
reproduction.
Mozart in 1777 with his papal insignia
Whether that party anecdote actually happened
is as difficult to determine as many other
details of this tale.
But what is 100% verifiable fact is that news
of this supposedly extremely accurate unauthorized
copy of Miserere eventually reached Pope Clement
XIV (perhaps even via Leopold Mozart himself
spilling the beans to the Pope in a letter).
The Pope then summoned the young composer
to Rome while Mozart was travelling through
Naples.
However, rather than being upset or excommunicating
Mozart, the Pope was impressed by the young
composer’s musical ability and initiative
and instead awarded him the Chivalric Order
of the Golden Spur– essentially a Papal
knighthood.
This, perhaps, gives credence to the notion
that Mozart’s copy of the work must have
been reasonably accurate, as presumably the
Pope would have checked with his Maestro di
Cappella concerning Mozart’s transcription
before awarding such an honour.
This knighthood was something Mozart seems
to have been extremely proud of, including
frequently wearing the cross medal that came
with being knighted.
He also took to signing his name Chevalier
de Mozart.
However, in a letter to his father dated October
of 1777, the 21 year old Mozart reveals that,
during a concert in which various nobles were
in attendance, Mozart wore the mark of his
papal knighthood and the nobles mocked him
for it, after which he seems to have ceased
wearing it and further stopped signing his
name with the title.
In any event, impressed by Mozart and no doubt
realising, both based on Mozart’s transcription
of the work and the others that existed at
the time, that the cat was out of the bag
(or perhaps simply not caring as his predecessors
had), Pope Clement XIV got rid of the ban
concerning copies of the music for Miserere,
ostensibly making it available to the masses.
However, due to the abbellimenti that the
Papal Choir employed when they performed the
piece, compared to what the stock music said,
for almost a century more the true Vatican
version of the song remained something you
could only hear at the Vatican.
It wouldn’t be until 1840 when a Catholic
priest by the name of Pietro Alfieri published
the embellished version of Miserere that the
world finally had what is considered to be
an accurate sheet music representation of
the Chapel Choir
version
of song.